congratulations you just started your
new job at the scp foundation as a
junior researcher
we help you survive long enough to
retire and collect your foundation
pension
but you've got a lot to learn before you
can even think about that
you're here to find out more about some
of the most mysterious entities known to
man
and the foundation depends on you to do
your job right
or the world might not see tomorrow but
hey
no pressure you're gonna hear a lot of
new terminology on the job
big scary words like apollyon and
thalmatology
and of course euclid and ketter
the two most common containment
classifications
today we're going to answer a question
that's been on a lot of people's minds
what do these classifications actually
mean and what's the difference between
them
first it must be noted that these
classes don't have much to do with
danger as you may
think instead object classes are all
about how difficult an anomaly
is to contain and we're going to take
you on a crash course of each of them
and provide some examples so you can
broaden your idea of what exactly
euclid ketter and all the other classes
of anomalies can be
of course while euclid and ketter are
perhaps the best known object classes
they aren't the only ones just below
them in terms of severity
is the safe class it may be every guard
in d-class's dream to get assigned to
safe scps but this classification
doesn't mean the anomaly in question is
harmless it does mean that they are easy
to contain though
often requiring very few resources or
certain specific activation mechanisms
for example scp-507 the unwilling
dimension hopper
the unwilling dimension hopper is fully
cooperative with foundation containment
protocols
earning him the safe class scp-662
the butler's handbell while capable of
extreme violence doesn't activate unless
someone rings it
making it safe to store and of course
scp-999 the tickle monster earned its
safe rating by essentially wanting to
keep foundation staff pleased at every
turn
and requiring virtually nothing in the
way of containment
euclid comes next this class actually
has the widest scope of any object class
under foundation control and the grand
majority of objects fall under this
banner
unlike safe class anomalies euclid
anomalies require greater resources to
keep contained
the euclid classification can also mean
that containment isn't always reliable
and is often given due to either a lack
of knowledge about the anomaly
or there being some degree of inherent
unpredictability
unpredictable is really the key word
when it comes to euclid scps
anomalies that are either autonomous
meaning they can move on their own
sentient meaning that they're capable of
thought or sapient
meaning they are partially intelligent
almost always automatically fall
into the euclid class this is because
anything that moves or thinks on its own
is capable of surprising
and unpredictable behavior
notwithstanding certain exceptions like
the aforementioned
tickle monster this brings us to ketter
in the simplest terms you could describe
keter class anomalies as
euclid but worse again this has nothing
to do with how violent or dangerous the
anomaly
is merely how difficult it is to contain
ketter class anomalies often require
extensive resources to fully contain
containment methods are also often extra
thorough and complex
though when it comes to a ketter class
anomaly there's no guarantee the methods
will be 100 percent effective
there are a number of reasons an scp can
slip into ketter territory
including but not limited to extreme
aggression and its frequent escape
attempts existing in large numbers over
a wide area
and having anomalous abilities that make
them particularly difficult to contain
like teleportation or the ability to
walk through walls
to better explain this foundation
researchers have devised a simple method
known as the locked box test
if you were to leave an item inside a
locked box and stop supervising it
and it's still there when you get back
then the item is probably
safe if you leave an item inside a
locked box without supervision and
you're not sure
what exactly will happen then it's
probably euclid
if you leave an item inside a locked box
without supervision and it easily breaks
free
then you likely have a ketter object on
your hands or rather
did before it broke out and ran off
before we go any further
it's worth briefly mentioning that there
are two other primary object classes
that cover most scps that aren't under
the safe
euclid and ketter banners these are
thomial
and neutralized thaumial anomalies are
scps that are used to contain
other scps such as scp-3000
the legendary amnestic producing
anatashia
neutralized anomalies are objects that
either have lost their anomalous
qualities or been straight up destroyed
a good example being scp-1762
the cardboard box which used to contain
the land of fantasy
but back to euclid and ketter what are
some good examples of euclid and ketter
class anomalies in containment
right now let's take a look at some of
the foundation's most
iconic euclid classes first kicking
things off we have scp-096
also known as the shy guy we all know
and fear this self-conscious serial
killing monster that murders anything
that sees its face
as you already know when someone sees
the face of the shy guy
nothing can stand in its way on its
quest to utterly destroy them
the monster has not only proven
successful in causing mass casualty
events
it's also pretty much indestructible and
has shown that it's able to tear its way
out of containment with ease
so you may be wondering why is the shy
guy euclid and not ketter
well it may surprise you to hear this
scp-096 is actually closer to safe
than ketter the monster may be
incredibly dangerous when its rage state
is activated
but it's proven fairly easy for the
foundation to control this activation
the only times that 096 has breached
containment is when photographs of its
face have been found out in the real
world
but as long as the foundation can
prevent people from seeing its face
it poses no real risk of containment
breach the very fact that the foundation
can't know for sure how many photos of
it are out there
adds an element of unpredictability to
its containment
and that is why despite being incredibly
scary and dangerous
096 is firmly euclid
next another euclid anomaly that needs
no introduction
scp-173 also known as the sculpture
this nasty piece of modern art has given
workers at the foundation many a
sleepless night thanks to its terrifying
tendency to
snap the necks of anyone who isn't
looking at it this
is a creature so scary that even scp-682
feels uncomfortable around it
much like scp-096 173 has also proved
nigh
impossible to kill and in a containment
breach
it's been known to stack up bodies like
it was judgment day
so why just euclid rather than ketter
once again it all comes down to how the
foundation
understands just how ticks
as everyone knows by now 173 is
paralyzed whenever someone is looking at
it
as a result the foundation has been able
to devise containment methods that
center around keeping 173 constantly
observed
the reason it's euclid rather than safe
is that while quite reliable
this method is also somewhat time and
resource intensive
as with anything that requires a high
degree of human involvement
the potential for human error is always
there
and finally in our rundown of famous
euclid class objects we have
scp-3008 more broadly known as the
infinite ikea this sinister retail giant
is a pocket dimension hiding within an
ikea
superstore leading to what seems to be
an infinite furniture warehouse
filled with scary faceless creatures
known as the staff
hundreds or perhaps even thousands of
people have become trapped in scp-3008
and it may even connect to other
dimensions this is one place where you
really
really don't want to get stuck while
shopping for a new piece of furniture
but it's still euclid why well because
to the best of our knowledge there's
only one gateway into 3008's pocket
dimension
inside our reality and the foundation
has that specific site
on lockdown while there are still things
we don't know about scp-3008
the foundation has been able to secure
and contain the entrance
it's euclid rather than safe because
this entrance still needs to be
patrolled regularly to ward off any
staff attempting to escape
and prevent further victims from
entering which is a low risk but
resource heavy job
next up is keter class first we have the
terrifying
scp-682 also known as the hard to
destroy reptile
anyone who's seen our videos on this
nasty creature knows that it really
really lives up to that name 682 may not
be the most dangerous scp
especially with cosmic monsters like the
scarlet king and the devourer of worlds
out there
but it's one of the most hardy thanks to
its incredible adaptive
abilities because of the way 682 adapts
to pretty much any threat
it's virtually impossible to attack it
the same way twice
however if being violent and
indestructible was all it took to become
a ketter class anomaly
the shy guy would be right there with it
there are two key factors that push
682 into ketter territory it's
incredibly high intelligence and the
fact that it reacts
unpredictably to all external stimuli
because of its intelligence
682 is able to actively scheme to escape
containment
something it does with such regularity
that the foundation is constantly trying
to terminate it
and because of its adaptive abilities
its behavior in response to containment
is often nigh
impossible to predict as a result of all
of this
682 is a complete nightmare to keep
locked up
making it ketter next a ketter class
anomaly that's not quite as well known
and not nearly as ferocious scp-3663
also known as the tunnel monster or the
cardboard box monster
this entity is as scary as it is
incredibly sad
he was once a normal little boy playing
in an abandoned industrial area with his
friends
he had built himself a crude monster
costume out of cardboard boxes
but through anomalous means this costume
bonded with the little boy
turning his organs into cardboard and
twine
now it manifests in pipes and tunnels
across the country
approaching nearby humans and causing
paranoia and fear
it'll then grab his victims and
transport them elsewhere
leaving them unconscious and afraid but
otherwise
unharmed clearly we're not looking at an
anomaly even close to being as dangerous
and deadly to scp-682
but it's still very much ketter why
because the teleporting ability inherent
to scp-3663 makes it incredibly
difficult to consistently contain
along with its inherent distrust of
foundation personnel
the foundation have yet to devise a
truly effective containment method for
3663 and its teleporting antics
so ketter class is where it remains
despite it being
mostly benign and finally scp-1000
aka bigfoot this is one of the few
anomalies that genuinely holds the moral
high ground
over the foundation on account of them
formerly being an incredibly advanced
species almost
wiped out by humanity in the past now
the foundation is feeding everyone the
lie that even looking at one of these
creatures can result
in death even though it can't the
reality is that the foundation hopes to
keep
scp-1000 suppressed fearing that if they
ever regained their former glory
they would surely oppress humanity just
as humanity had oppressed them
even though once again it doesn't appear
that scp-1000 has
any such malicious intentions so why are
these abnormally large and abnormally
intelligent apes cater class once again
it all comes down to two facts tipping
the classification
scales and in this case those are
population
and dispersion there are a lot of these
creatures out there
especially across north america and the
fact they appear in forests all across
the country makes it
incredibly difficult for the foundation
to keep a lid on them
seeing as a civilian simply seeing an
scp-1000 specimen constitutes a
containment breach
these happen frequently especially if
you run encrypted and conspiracy circles
and are out actually
looking to meet one that brings us to
the end of our crash course on euclid
and ketter class anomalies
we hope you enjoyed your stay and
managed to survive all the strange and
horrific entities we've covered
let us know if you've enjoyed this video
in the comments and want to see more of
the ins and outs of the scp foundation's
classification
system explained but for now you're
finally ready to start your research
role at the scp foundation
just make sure you've got your last will
and testament written before your first
day
now check out scp chaos insurgency
explained
and scp-001 which is the real zero zero
one
for more of the foundation's most top
secret files